ein kurzfilm mit motiven aus bern ag
shiraz zeichnungen
ich mag seine persönlichkeit
ich mag seine zeichnung und ich mag
seinen cinematographie den zugang zu
kunst er zeichnet im grunde
perspektivische filmszene und in diesem
projekt ging es uns darum etwas zu tun
bei dem wir beide neulinge sind also
haben wir uns entschieden gemeinsam in
den film zu machen
der kurzfilm hat keine handlung
stattdessen fängt er die atmosphäre
eines amerikanischen roadmovies ein
berner ist fasziniert von den usa die er
schon mehrere male besucht hat als
regisseur hat werner eine klare
vorstellung genauso ist es bei rallye
der die kamera bedient und zwei künstler
an einem set kann das gut gehen
manchmal ist er nicht mit mir
einverstanden und manchmal bin ich nicht
mit ihm einverstanden
das ist halt so zum beispiel markus
bernhardt wenn alles sehr scharf
dargestellt wird
ich wiederum mag auch unschärfen
verschwommenen einstellung aber es ist
wie auf einer gemeinsamen reise man muss
sich absprechen wie es weitergehen soll
nein wir werden nicht den ganzen film
verschwommen nach action nach dem dreh
geht's ans vision ihren die eben
gedrehte szene ist für berner besonders
wichtig wer sind die zwei personen im
auto das er und joana und wer ist
johanna sie arbeitet am selben ort wobei
er nahe arbeitet weiß wie das im film
vorkommt
jetzt wird sie es wissen
werner grosch ihrer kam mit seiner
behinderung zur welt
er wurde zur adoption freigegeben und
wuchs bei einer pflegefamilie auf ein
leben mit vielen hürden umso
beeindruckender ist seine lebensfreude
mit berna zu arbeiten relativiert sehr
vieles den umgang mit der zeitnot rapp
unser selbstverständnis vom menschsein
es ist eine sehr wertvolle begegnungen
dabei eine faszinierende innenwelt und
nimmt uns mit auf seine reise
[Musik]
die zusammenarbeit hat ihre freundschaft
gefestigt und am ende des drehtages
verrät werner dann auch wieder film
heißen soll
extraordinär ein außergewöhnlicher traum
[Musik]